como todos los años frente al congreso
de la nación argentina se llevó a cabo
esta convocatoria por el Día
Internacional de la mujer aquí en la
ciudad de Buenos Aires es una de las
muchas que se llevan a cabo en toda
Argentina este año hay un reclamo muy
fuerte en torno a la equidad laboral la
falta de equidad laboral y a la
violencia de género también una
exigencia de que se incorpore la
perspectiva de género definitivamente en
el ámbito de la justicia y que se
repartan de mejor forma las tareas de
Cuidado Pero además recordemos que
movilizaciones como esta del Ocho hoy
mejoró las que lograron con La potencia
de la calle que el congreso aprobara en
el año 2020 la ley del aborto legal
seguro y gratuito en Argentina algo que
también se está reclamando que
simplemente correcta Y definitivamente
en esta marcha que tiene lugar este 8 de
marzo en la ciudad de Buenos Aires
[Música]